Guys... guys... messed up.
You must be wondering, wow, Doki, you sound very dead inside.
Very, very good observation.
Because I am.
Okay, guys.
Okay, so, you know... you know how our goal... one of our goals is to end in a...
Oh, my fashion... what?
Wait, what?
Okay, alright, we're not starting yet.
I'm just chilling.
Wait, am I gonna be like in there already?
And then people are gonna be like, wow, she didn't even try.
I didn't know the game started.
You know what, let's just watch the fashion show.
While I talk about...
Okay, total new lobby.
What the fuck?
Thank you for one billion... there's enough children for one billion visits?
Decorate a free section?
Oh, that's me.
That's me.
Alright.
Anyway.
The game's graphics have been changed.
If your graphics are in a high level and experience...
Okay, I am a... I'm not a child.
Okay, I have... I am an adult.
With my own credit card.
I'm ready to be...
Why would this lag?
It's literally a fashion show.
Why would this be laggy?
Hey!
It's literally Brad's dolls.
With fucking clothes.
Okay, it'll be funny if I'm actually in here.
Um...
But like...
Anyway...
So, holy shit!
Look at her go!
Okay, maybe I'll be way too distracted if I...
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna close this.
I'm definitely gonna be way too distracted.
Okay.
Alright.
I have to close it.
Because I'm gonna be too...
I can't finish my story if I look at this.
It's a fashion show.
Okay.
Um...
Um, as I was saying...
So, okay.
So, one of my goals is that I wanna end...
I wanna end Top 500 in Overwatch.
I'm back.
It's back.
You know, like...
Whenever you're in the very...
Whenever you're...
You're like...
I'll never come back.
And then the game was like...
No, you'll always come back, Doki.
You know I'm the only one that loves you, Doki.
You know you could never leave.
So, it's like a very...
You know...
A very abusive relationship with this game.
And I'll be like...
No, I will never...
No, I won't.
I got help this time.
I'll never come back to you.
And then later on, you're just like...
Oh, but like...
He's changed, guys.
It's like fun now.
I swear.
I swear, Dragoons.
It's actually fun now, guys.
And then everybody else around me is like...
No, Doki, please.
Please, you have to finally leave.
Is he...
No, but you don't understand.
Dragoons, I can...
I can fix it.
Guys, no.
It wasn't...
He...
He wasn't the issue.
I was the issue.
I was the issue, guys.
Anyway.
So I...
I'm back on it.
And...
Basically, I played Overwatch for...
For a long time.
After...
Because like today, yesterday...
I had to...
I know I left Overwatch several times, but this time for real, they're bringing 6v6 back, chat.
They're bringing 6v6 back, guys.
He's going back to his roots.
I have to be there for Overwatch.
You know?
Okay, anyway.
It's different this time.
They're bringing 6v6!
They're bringing back Overwatch 1!
You don't understand!
Bro, Overwatch 1 with fucking the tanks that they have now?
Oh my god, I'm like thinking Zarya, Mogg, and...
...Mogg is gonna be fucking insane.
Like, Zarya with any of the tanks that we have currently.
And we're doing 6v6... Oh no, we're gonna bring back GOATS.
No, we're gonna bring back GOATS!
No!
Nevermind.
No, GOATS!
Sorry, that's...
The pain was so real in that.
I just... I forgot about GOATS.
People were like, what the fuck is she talking about?
A GOAT?
No, it's like, it's specific.
Okay, for those who don't play Overwatch, it is actually like...
It's a very specific comp.
Where it's 3 tanks and 3 supports.
And, like, they don't die.
Nobody dies.
And...
And GOATS was fucking terrible.
Because it's literally every fucking game in high elo.
Because if you're fucking desperate enough, you'd be like, please guys, this is my top 500 game.
Please, can we go GOATS?
Can we please go GOATS?
And... and the reason why people really, really fucking hated that...
That, like, particular meta, that comp with 3 tanks, 3 supports.
Is that...
Is that, basically...
It's an alt battle.
It's whoever fucks up the alt first.
Because everybody just farms alt.
And then... and then it's whoever fucks up alt.
Whoever fucks up their ultimate loses the team fight.
And it's so fucking frustrating.
At least we have... at least we have role queue.
So there's no way... there's no way!
There's no way GOATS!
GOATS will be back!
We'll just have 2 really fucking stupid overpowered tanks this time!
We'll just have incredibly overpowered tanks.
And it's just going to be 2 of them.
No!
If they can't physically bring back GOATS!
Because it's...
Dude, dude, dude!
DPS is just going to be a worthless role!
But when have they been worth anything in the last 2 years?
Like...
All the DPS players left to play other games where they can actually shoot their gun.
So it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Oh my god.
Anyway...
So... I have a problem right now.
That's been happening for like a while.
For...
For like a... um...
I have a problem.
And that's why I'm dead inside at the moment.
Because I did not sleep much today.
Because I was like...
After the...
After the panel in Singapore...
I fucking...
I...
I went and played Overwatch.
But...
Yes...
I took Q today.
I took Q last night.
Guys...
For those who don't know...
What it means...
To take Q in Overwatch...
I had my longest lost streak...
Since...
I had the longest lost streak...
That I ever had...
In a very long time.
And then you know you're like...
I can't stop until I break the lost streak.
I can't stop until I break the lost streak guys.
Or...
So...
I was...
Masters 2.
And then...
And then I took Q...
To Masters 4.
And I'm at the...
And I am at the bottom run of Masters 4.
Like I'm nearly one game away from losing Masters 4.
For those who don't understand...
How bad it is to...
To lose that much...
Masters 2...
Masters 1...
Is top 500.
And not just top 500.
It's rank 300 to 500.
That's Masters 1.
And I was Masters 2.
I was...
So close.
I was so close!
But yeah.
That's why...
Now I'm that guy that went from...
No!
It's Masters 4!
I didn't get down there yet!
I'll get back!
I can get it back guys!
Today I'll get my Masters 2 back!
I might have meet and greets and a battle!
I'm gonna battle at ACG HK at Hong Kong, but I'll get it back!
Stop get some help.
Why do you think I'm playing Dress to impress?
Let's go gambling!
Can't say thank you.
Thank you.
You have a loved one suffering from overwatch relax Please call this toll-free number.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you fake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Seeing you on the Evo cast was sick.
Hope you watch again next year.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you I really appreciate it.
I'm glad you guys enjoyed Evo.
That was fun doing the casting.
Alright Dress to impress Yahoo I'm gonna be so fashionable All right Aquatic oh Oh Okay for those who don't know apparently this is the new hit game right now and I have no idea why Oh You know what?
I want to know what I want to know But do I need all of this do any custom makeup, why would I need a run fat holy shit the amount of names they have fucking Bye.
Oh, that's That's so cute!
This game is apparently incredibly popular right now in the streaming community.
Like, apparently, even Keiso is playing it.
And for those who are like, who the fuck is Keiso?
Keiso is this generation's Tyler1.
So that would give us the little context here.
So... it's... it... yeah... it's...
Oh!
And Alexo is like, oh that guy!
That one!
Um... literally who?
Yeah, like... that's when you know you're not from this generation right now.
It's um... basically every generation...
Um... every generation has a... um... has their own Tyler1.
This is... this is Gen Z's Tyler1.
Um...
Who's Tyler1?
Okay... This is...
For those who don't know who Tyler1 is...
Tyler1 is the old generations...
Um...
Is the old... old generation...
Uh...
Keiso!
he's... he's... he's... he's like...
Like, our generation's Kaiso, for those who don't know who Tyler1 is.
I guess I was like, he's still relevant!
I swear!
Oh my god, I'm naked!
Oh, I don't... oh my god.
Oh no.
Alright, I turned down the overall volume of sound guide.
Oh, you want me to bring down... I don't even know if that's possible!
Oh, there it is!
Okay, maybe if I... okay, let's see...
Alright, there we go.
I brought down the music a little bit too.
Alright.
Okay, Kaiso... okay, basically every generation means...
Oh my god, look at my strut.
Oh, it's intermission!
Hey guys!
I'm the new girl in town!
I'm gonna...
Oh my god, Slay!
Kaiso, I could go for some cheese!
Yeah, thank you super chat!
Thank you!
Okay, so for those who don't know, either of those people...
Oh my god!
I need to grab money, because I'm poor!
This is so fucked up!
Queen of Hearts?
I don't know!
Alright... let's see... All right, and then...
Um... no, I have to be red- No, oh, oh wait!
This works!
This works, guys.
This works.
And then we gotta grab some money because we're fucking broke as hell.
Alright, so every generation, we need a streamer that likes to...
Okay, we gotta do hair.
Sorry, give me a sec.
Oh, this one.
Okay.
That has to be!
That's bangs?
Do we need bangs?
That's Queen of Hearts material!
And then... oh...
Okay, no, I can't!
I can't do like...
Two double colors.
God damn it, I can't do double colors!
I have to get rid of it.
Okay.
Alright, how do I get out of the chair?
How do I get out of the chair?
I finished it.
HOW DO I GET OUT OF THE CHAAAA- Okay, okay.
I don't do well under time limit, guys.
I don't know if you noticed, but I don't do well when I'm...
No, I'm not!
I'm not in the prank!
Oh no.
No, I got the hair though!
I got the hair!
There's so- Oh, how did she get that?
Wait, I'm gonna copy your clothes.
Wait, a thousand dollars?
I'm not that rich in Roblox money!
I'm gonna put a cellphone though.
Oh...
Cause Queen of Hearts is a fucking boss bitch.
And she's ready to- Oh, this doesn't need- Okay, this is bullshit that this doesn't need.
Uh, this doesn't need money.
Wait, what do I wear?
What can I afford?
What can I- Oh, okay, maybe I can afford this.
Okay, uh, patterns.
Do I have any heart patterns?
I- I- Oh my gosh.
Okay, I have three minutes.
Uh, the most ugliest part!
What a statement of society.
Right there.
Damn!
This is a fucking statement.
No, I need a shirt, guys!
Oh my- Okay, I still have three minutes, guys.
I still have three minutes.
I think I look pretty fucking good, not gonna lie.
I- I think I look really good.
Alright, no, not the men clothing.
It says Queen of Hearts.
Where the fuck- I need a shirt!
We live in a society.
No, what is this?
No, I'm excluded!
This is the poor!
The poor!
Come on,
we're in the poor section!
No!
Society wins!
No, don't recognize it!
They've been playing Dressed in Frisk for 20 years!
They know what the poor section looks like!
I'm back.
I- I- How about blue screen?
It's ROBLOX!
How the fuck- How the fuck am I- Alright, guys, I'm gonna- I'm gonna get rid of this Intel card.
I think it's Intel.
It's always- I think it's Intel.
Alright.
I think- Oh my god!
I actually got kicked out of- I was so- I was- I was panicking.
I was- I was panicking about the Queen of Hearts.
And then- and then I- and then- and then they kicked me out.
They kicked me- I couldn't even fit!
Okay, I think I know why, guys.
I think I might know why.
It could be- okay, I think I fucked up.
By down- underclocking my PC for Marvel Rivals.
So, cause like, I think that's what did it.
I think that's what happened!
I don't know- I wonder if I could like, fix it, like, manually.
But, basically, um, I underclocked, uh, I underclocked my PC cause it was recommended by the game.
Um, to- to underclock it.
To, uh, to- to like- To like, 53X.
And, yeah, I undervault- yeah, I undervaulted.
Because, like, Marvel Rivals would not boot up.
And then Marvel Rivals has like a recommendation.
Um, that was like, we can't run this game on Intel 13.
So, it- you have to under- undervault it.
Sorry, I meant- yeah, I undervaulted, guys.
But then I revaulted it after the stream.
So, like, I- I undid the undervault.
And, uh- I- I- it was recommended by the game.
So, I did that.
And, uh- And- and I think after that, that's when the blue screen happened.
So, um...
Do I- just- yeah- yeah, so, like, I think that's what happened.
Because the game- Marvel Rivals- Cannot run- um- cannot run, uh- The game- you cannot run the- the game will crash, basically.
The game will crash if, uh...
Uh...
I grilled my CPU?
Did I actually did that?
I did one stream!
I did one fucking stream!
Oh my god!
I did one stream and my CPU is...
It's already fucked!
What?!
Oh my god!
But I redid it!
I- I- I didn't play Marvel Rivals for that long!
Like...
There's no way!
Do I- do I keep it undervaulted?
Do I actually keep it undervaulted for- until- I don't know!
Oh my god!
Bro...
It's not-
Yeah...
Yeah, basically...
Uh...
Yeah?
Okay, I'll keep it...
Uh...
I'll- it could help.
Okay, I'll keep- I'll keep it undervaulted then.
I had it, like...
Uh...
Because, like, now I- after the Marvel Rivals stream, I re- I did it back to- I did it...
Um...
I did it back to...
Uh...
To the original.
Um...
But then, like...
Then I started- then the- the blue screen started happening...
For the stream.
I think that's what hap- I think that's what happened to PC-kun too!
That's- I think...
I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure that's also what happened to- Okay, I...
I changed the performance core ratio.
I'm gonna go back to 53 then.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and put an AMD...
I'm gonna do that on the weekend.
Um...
Because, like, you know, there's- there's so much stuff going on.
I hate it!
Alright!
I...
I undervaulted!
I undervaulted it again.
So...
Um...
We'll see if this works.
I- I forced the undervault.
Alright.
This is the weekend.
I...
There's a lot going on.
Guys, I- Never!
Thank you for the five gifted chips!
Thank you!
Oh, no...
I need it.
This PC is so heavy!
Oh, my God!
And an AMD motherboard!
Oh...
Alright.
Anyway, I guess I'll- I'll look into that tomorrow.
I'll look in- I'll do- I need a- I just got this PC!
Oh, my God!
I just- I just bought this PC- Like, I- Okay, to be fair, I got this PC for free.
But now I'm spending money on this PC.
Now I'm spending money- Holy shit!
I'm spending money on this PC!
Even though I just got it.
Even though I got it for free...
Anyway, are you guys sure?
Are you guys sure I should keep it, like, undervote?
Or- Or- Because, like, it's been on- I only had it undervoted for Marvel Rivals and then I- Uh, I only, um...
Uh, I only have it undervoted for Marvel Rivals and then I did it back to, uh, the And then I did it back to the original vault, which was 57x.
Just to be safe?
Yes, it could die.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll... yeah.
Okay, I'll do... I'll keep it undervaulted.
Alright!
I can't believe it.
There's too much vault charge in Roblox.
It's fucking Roblox!
Alright,
what's the new... what's the new... new...
Okay, anyway.
As I was saying...
Oh, choose the next theme?
Oh!
I don't... okay, I want...
I want FNAF.
Not enough theme props?!
I don't have...
Okay, I'm too poor to choose.
Guys...
Guys, they won't let me pick because I'm too poor.
I don't... I can't pick because I'm too poor.
The theme is Ghost vs.
Ghoul.
Okay, Ghost vs.
Ghoul is in the poor section.
I wish I had Queen of Hearts!
I wish...
Wow!
She flipping!
Okay, I need the money.
I need... I need...
She's already has clothes on?!
Ghost vs Ghouls...
Ghost!
I'll be a ghost!
Ghosts are easy!
Okay, um...
What is spooky?
What... What is spooky?
Um...
Oh my god, what is a spooky?
What is a sp... Oh!
Okay, there you go.
Oh, she looks like, you know, a screamer.
She looks like a screaming ghost.
And then all white.
Okay.
Uh, and then bangs.
Uh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't like that.
Let's do like...
Full white bangs.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
Wait, I can combine?
Uh...
I'll do bangs.
That'll be cute.
Okay, nice.
All right.
They'll be unique.
Yeah, there you go.
I'm unique.
Okay, um...
We're...
How do I not be...
How do I not be blue?
Oh, it's makeup.
Oh, I can have...
I need money for makeup.
Oh...
I'm poor.
I can't believe it.
I need money for makeup.
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
All right.
That's cute.
Right?
Oh, god.
Okay.
Um...
Yeah, that's fine.
I'll do that.
Okay.
Why am I blue?
I don't want to be blue.
Okay.
Oh, screen isn't cropped.
No!
My screen isn't cropped correctly!
I'm sorry.
I'm a mess right now.
I'm a fucking mess.
I'm a...
No!
Guys, please.
Please give me some time.
Please, children.
Children, please!
Please!
Children!
Children, let me have a little bib time!
Children, please.
Anyone say, nobody wants to talk to the poor.
Nobody...
God's...
Nobody wants to talk to the poor.
Um...
What is...
Oh, I can be an old Victorian ghoul.
No.
Okay.
No, that's ugly.
Never mind.
Oh, I can be a...
Oh, I can have a necklace!
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, your outfit is...
Your
outfit is so good!
What I was...
I'm gonna copy your shit.
Fuck you, bitch.
I...
I'm gonna steal your fit.
I'm gonna do it.
I ain't no fucking...
I'm not scared.
I'm gonna steal your fucking fit.
All right.
Um...
Have some empathy, children.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Wait.
Oh, fuck.
I don't want this.
How do I take it off?
How do I...
Oh, no.
Okay.
Um...
I don't...
I...
Um...
Yes, I'm gonna...
No!
Okay.
We're gonna make do with this.
We're gonna...
It's not what I want to take off.
I only have a minute left.
I'm...
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay right now.
I'm not...
I mean, I'm not okay at the moment.
Um...
I want...
Uh...
Okay.
There we go.
That's...
Gooly.
Oh, okay.
No, not like that.
How do I get the other color?
I want to change that color.
Oh, over here.
Okay.
Uh...
There we go.
Does this feel...
Cool?
Oh, this is terrible.
This is so bad.
Everybody else looks so good.
That is not Ghost vs Ghouls.
Get the fuck out of here.
Attack some Squidward.
How do they change?
How do they...
Oh, it's a Ghoul.
Wait.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Guys, we're still...
How do I change my color?
How do I...
No, I'm too poor for that section.
No, stop telling me how poor I am.
That's a...
That's a zombie that looks like Squidward.
Oh, nice.
I got $18.
How do I...
How do I change...
Is it here?
Oh, it's my nails.
Okay.
Um...
There we go.
Nice.
Slay, girl.
See, if you have no money, it's okay.
The pods?
There's pods?
Where the pop people at?
The white lights near the jeans?
The fact that you guys know so much about this scares me a little.
Because it tells me that you guys definitely spent money on this game.
Like, shoes.
Shoes!
I'm fucking...
I have no shoes!
Oh, no.
Where are the shoes at?
Okay, I'm gonna put these on.
I don't have anything else, guys.
I don't...
I'm...
My internet is seed.
Guys.
Nooooo!
My internet!
I- Are you fucking- My internet- I'll never be able to show my fit!
I'll never- I'll never be able to- What is wrong with me today?!
I'll never be able to be fashionable!
I just wanna be fashionable.
I just wanna be fashionable with the children.
I can't.
Why is Roblox... Why?
Why are you like this?
Roblox!
No, I can't even...
I don't want to stop my Roblox.
Why is everything not working?
Everything is not okay.
Nothing is okay right now.
It's the arcade!
Okay, we're doing this again!
Oh my god, I feel so far right now.
I feel like I am roleplaying as a...
My internet...
I forgot to pay my internet bills.
I have to be poor!
Like, I have to be VIP.
Everything is full of me.
Today is not the day.
I never get to show my face at all.
So, fuck.
I fucking will be very fast.
Very fast.
It's going to be...
Horror!
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna be a fucking star.
No money, no internet.
Children bullying me.
I just wanna be Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear.
I don't know what is Freddy.
They won't know.
They're gonna be like, what the fuck is wrong with this bitch's fucking fit?
Like, I'm sorry, I'm trying my best.
I am.
I really am.
I don't know what else would Freddy Fazbear...
What would Freddy Fazbear look like if he was...
If he had...
If he was a bear.
Oh, this, this, this.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Wait, this is what he'll look like if he was a bear.
Wait, I mean if...
Sorry.
This is what he'll look like if he was a person.
He's already...
A bear.
Sorry, he's already...
Guys, I'm not okay right now.
I DC'd twice.
I DC'd.
And then I fucking blue screen like...
Pick a struggle.
Okay.
Pick a fucking struggle in lane.
And I'm getting bullied by children.
Who have spent their mom's credit card money.
Okay.
No, I don't have $5,000.
I don't even know how much money I have.
How much money I do have.
Like...
Holy shit.
I'm trying to be Freddy Fazbear from the arcades.
That's themed.
That's a theme right now.
Okay.
I'm trying.
Do I...
Oh my god.
He picked Penelope.
Okay.
I'm trying to know what pants to wear.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Do I have to...
That's a fucking dolphin.
That's nice.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
Freddy Fazbear.
Okay.
I need to change my...
I need...
I need to get pants.
Like...
I don't know.
I need to get pants.
Oh.
Okay.
There we go.
And then let me change my clothes.
Okay.
Oh.
I don't know.
What tone is that?
There you go.
Hoor.
That's a fucking dolphin.
Like what?
That's not even...
Oh no.
17 seconds.
I need pants.
Um...
What goes well?
Ah.
Oh.
This doesn't look good.
I put everything on.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
Oh god.
Okay.
Do you think they'll recognize it?
Do you guys think the children will recognize it?
Okay.
You're not even trying.
You're not even one star.
That's not even...
You're not even trying your best right now.
Like what is this?
What is this?
You just put everything on.
Oh.
Wait.
They put...
What the fuck?
Bro...
Brian's a runaway queen?
Three stars.
Oh my god.
Brian is a...
And he's doing the Mario poses.
Oh.
These kids.
Who the fuck is Lucille?
What are you?
One star.
Like what are you?
You're just going to the god damn mall.
Like this is not a fit...
That's just a girl.
That's just...
Okay.
That's just a girl.
Like at least...
Bro!
That's two girls!
These...
You do not see these girls in a fucking arcade.
Like...
That is not arcade material.
How are you going to play?
How are you going to play the drum game in that fit?
Girl.
Your makeup's going to run with full of sweat because you're trying too hard.
So true.
But she has...
Oh my god.
She plays... you can't even play!
What's this?
It's not arcade.
You don't even... you can't even... you're a fashion maven?
Go back to fashion school.
What is that?
What the fuck?
What are you?
Getting...
Trying to get some bitches?
Like what?
Oh, you're gonna jump around?
That is not Mario.
Oh the fashion maven.
One star.
This is not to the theme.
Guys, guys, do they think they notice that I'm Freddy Fazbear?
Do they think they have from the arcade?
Yeah, oh I'm so confident right there.
They have Luigi?
Oh my god!
Three stars.
I'm like the Asia star rating because in Asia apparently people don't rate... people don't rate above three stars.
Wait, no.
No, that's a minion.
Wait a minute.
That's a fucking minion.
That's not even arcade.
That's a good costume.
But that's... not to theme.
Not to theme.
Girl, you cannot... you cannot do that and just not be to theme.
Oh wait you can...
Oh my... this is not fair.
She's clearly rich.
This is not fair.
Three stars.
That is cheating!
She clearly has money!
Like, this is so fucked!
You're clearly... I... this is not fair!
They went in with Mario and Luigi!
Oh, I got fourth!
I got fourth!
Yeah, fuck you bitches!
I might be poor, but I have style and fashion.
I knew what the kids like, and the kids like FNAF!
I know!
I knew what the children like to see, and the children like...
Not last.
I got third place for the first time.
Oh my God!
Guys!
This is my first game and I got fourth place.
I'm scared.
Oh my god, yes, slay!
Anyway...
Let me win then.
Luigi isn't a girl!
It's a man!
What the f***?
Shit.
Bro, okay.
Wait, how do I get rid of my clothes?
Okay, how do I get rid of my makeup?
What is this?
Um...
How do I get rid of my makeup?
First Lady?
Oh shit, what the f***?
Okay.
Um, white.
Um...
I don't know.
We don't have First Ladies.
We have Prime Ministers.
And...
First Minister?
First Lady Minister?
What do we call him?
Do we call the Prime Minister his wife?
What do we even call the Prime Minister's wife?
I don't f***ing know.
What do we call the First Prime?
Prime Lady?
Like...
Yeah, we just call her wife!
She's just wife!
Like...
I'm not American!
How the f*** am I supposed to know what the First Lady looks like?!
Okay.
Oh no.
Whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore.
Optimus Prime.
She's an expensive gal.
That's when you know this First Lady is f***ing committing tax fraud.
What is it called when they dip into the funds?
When...
When they start dipping into government funding?
Felony?
Yeah, but there's a word for it.
Embezzlement.
Yeah.
That's when you know my lady is embezzling.
That's when you know...
They always have the same haircut.
Like the...
Like...
No, not this one.
Oh, it's sort of like that, but short.
Like not...
Less wavy.
It's sort of like that, but...
Oh f*** it.
Let's just make Michelle Obama.
Like I'm already halfway.
I'm already there.
You know I'm already there.
I'm literally already there.
Okay.
Oh, f***.
F***ing weeb all.
Let's see.
There we go.
I think we're there.
I think...
I think we did it.
This is...
This should be her, right?
I don't know.
I don't pay attention to what's going on in America.
Oh, I need a bag!
You're right!
I need a bag!
All right.
There we go.
Easy.
Is there like a nicer bag?
Like a nicer, like...
I'm the first lady back.
You're so fake.
You're so first lady right now.
Wait.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like this, right?
Oh, she doesn't wear that hat.
I don't fucking know.
I don't remember what she wears.
Like, I barely pay attention to fashion anyway!
Thanks to Obama.
Thank you for the super chat.
That's so dead.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
Why is there a mermaid?
I don't fucking know why there's a mermaid here.
Like, this mermaid.
My god, you guys know more about the first lady than I do.
Stop it.
I'm not rich.
Somebody... guys, whoever stream... who my stream sniper?
Fucking stream snipe me as VIP right now.
Give me my...
Guys.
Guys, I'm...
I'm like... I'm the charity case guy.
I hate that you guys stream snipe me as well.
Give me a scholarship right now.
Give me a scholarship and get me out of here.
I don't wanna be poor anymore.
I don't wanna be poor and get bullied by children.
The first lady needs funding.
She can't keep embezzling.
Like, I'm like... fucking restricted.
I'm like... fucking restricted with everything.
There's like four hats here!
There's literally four hats!
Like...
Bro, you copied my fit!
I'm Michelle Obama!
That's not Michelle Obama!
Look at you!
You fucking...
Michelle Obama never wears red.
I think.
I don't know.
I don't pay attention.
I think.
I don't know.
I don't pay attention.
I did!
Fuck you bitch!
I, Michelle Obama, I claimed!
I claimed the Obamas first!
Like...
There's only room for one Michelle Obama.
I'm picking up for two Michelle's.
There's one!
It's not first ladies!
It's first lady!
Like, come on.
Mrs. President, Mrs. President, get down.
No, no, she's like conservative.
She's...
Today she doesn't want to show her legs.
She doesn't want to show her legs today, guys.
Um, okay.
She doesn't want to show her legs today!
She's gotta do it for the kids!
Jesus, that's not first lady!
What the fuck are you?
That's a...
That's Snow White!
That's a first lady princess.
Which founding father was a lady?
One star for not even being on theme.
What the fuck?
Oh, yes!
I got my scholarship!
Peace out, nerds!
I'm going to boarding school!
I'm going to a private boarding school!
I'm going to Ivy League now!
I'm crawled through from the poor to become...
to get my scholarship!
Yeah!
No shot!
No way!
One star, not even a theme!
That's... who is that?
Are you...
Wait!
EVE???
Michelle...
...Pilfer...
Holy shit, Michelle!
I can't believe Obama got censored!
How am I gonna do thanks Obama?
I can't...how am I gonna be scared?
How can I say thanks Obama?
Mama!
Who's Jackie?
That's a child!
Oh my god, that's a child!
Somebody literally said, who's Jackie?
Holy shit, who the fuck is he?
Oh no!
Yeah, I didn't do any poses because like, the first lady has to be very reserved and like...
Who the fuck?
Oh that is... what is that?
Dang, you don't have plans.
Okay, one star.
Everybody gets one star.
Yeah, but she does one hell of a split.
I like how everybody's like, who are you?
Oh my god.
One star, you fucking pit stealer!
Michelle would never win those fucking...
um... necklaces.
Michelle would never do a dead drop.
I literally searched Michelle in Pinterest.
I apologize.
You cheated!
You googled in Pinterest?
I did it from memory!
I did that from fucking memory!
And this bitch cheated.
I'm looking up on...
Pinterest.
It like, literally came to me in a dream.
Who are you?
I feel like I'm playing... I'm sorry Michelle, I failed you.
I'm playing in Olive Garden.
The wife of...
sucks.
What the fuck is this game?
I'm playing in Olive Garden.
Oh okay, this one's...
I recognize her.
Who is Jill?
At least you can blame on Olive Garden.
Guys, I have to be first place from that.
I did... YES!
I did it!
Thank you Obama!
Thank you!
Wait...
Thanks Obama!
Thank you!
Thank you Obama!
Thanks Michelle!
I can't even say thanks Obama!
I can't...
Even if I put it in space.
That's right.
I got my scholarship.
I ain't poor like you guys now.
I got it from Shira Will and being fabulous.
Thanks.
Oh my god.
I have VIP access now.
I...
The Roblox thing.
No, Obama is censored no matter what.
I can't even like... I can't even...
Um...
I can't even like fucking do it with like a space in between two.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm not a charity case.
I'm just special.
Then you could see how good I am.
At...
Mythology.
You guys are gonna be on the poor section.
See you later losers.
I'm fabulous enough.
Oh wings.
Oh my god.
Wings.
Mythology.
I'm gonna be a...
I'll be an angel.
That's not...
That didn't mean that.
I didn't...
Oh my god.
I could be Mikatsune.
Mikatsune is technically a mythological creature.
Okay.
Um...
I could be an elf.
Alright, here we go.
Um...
I wanna do like...
I wanna...
Uh...
What's his name?
The Hermes.
I wanna do Hermes.
Is there like...
Shoes with wings?
I'm gonna be Hermes.
Miku.
Who is legendary?
I'm gonna be Hermes.
Okay, let's see.
See you later.
I got the rich people section now.
Let's see, is there rich people here?
Let's see...
Where...
Yeah, I need wings on shoes but like where am I gonna find that?
What would Hermes look like if Hermes was a woman?
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
Whoa!
If Hermes was a woman, what would you look like?
To be fair, back then, like, they're turning into women and men and just fucking everything, to be fair.
So, like...
Wait, this is such a tiny area for the rich section.
That's it?
I'm rich and this is all I get?
The poor people get, like, 200,000, like...
Like, outfits.
That's not fair.
It's Hermes, not Inmes.
That's so true.
So...
So good.
Fucking hell, that's so fucking good.
What the fuck?
I mean...
That's fair.
They're ready sea creatures.
Like, what the...
What am I supposed to do with that?
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna...
I'm Hermes, but my wings are on my back instead of my shoes.
That's really good.
I know.
I was like, jeez.
Wait, what's this?
Ooh.
No.
Uh, wait.
Oh, oh, I know what that is.
Okay.
Let's see.
Is there a shoe I can put it on?
That's, like, vaguely wing-like.
Oh, okay.
We're gonna put on this.
Um...
Oh, I can be Valkyrie!
I'm supposed to be like, I'm Valkyrie!
Oh my god, you're right!
You're right!
I'm a Valkyrie!
Wait!
Oh my god, you guys are so smart.
You guys are so fucking smart.
Okay.
Uh...
That is the shoe base.
I need to change this.
Uh, I'll change it to...
Oh my god, you guys are so fucking smart, though.
Uh...
Let's see.
I'll do... I think you should be white, actually.
Alright, this is logical.
Holy fucking shit.
That's right, I'm a Valkyrie.
Okay.
I'm just gonna be like this this entire time.
Alright, let's see.
A minute and forty-eight seconds.
Is there a way... I need to get a sword!
I know!
Dude, I don't think they're gonna have swords!
I don't think they're gonna have swords in fucking ROBLOX!
I cannot even say... I can't even say, thanks, Obama!
You think they're gonna have swords?
Like, you really think?
You know?
If I can't even say, thanks, Obama!
You think they're gonna give swords in this game?
Alright, let's see.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
Maybe.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I got jewelry on.
I think it's good.
I think... That Twilight Sparkle!
Okay, tech, get to it.
Twilight Sparkle is in a mess!
She's real to me.
That's so fucked up.
What the fuck?
Okay.
We don't fuck...
You guys are saying there's like...
There's like a...
Yeah, I'm a Valkyrie!
A Valkyrie doesn't wear...
A Valkyrie doesn't even wear halos!
What do you mean?
Let's see.
Is there actually any wings on?
No, okay.
Uh...
God, I wish there was a sword.
I wish there was a sword!
It's not fair!
Where would I want a sword?
I think this is the perfect thing I can do.
This is the best I can do, guys, in this scenario.
I'll just be like, I'm a Valkyrie.
I'll... I'll...
Vote for me, children.
What else can I do?
What the fuck is this?
What is that?
I'm a disco ball because I didn't like this!
I'll give you two star for that.
I'll give you...
What
the fuck is she?
Is that Zeus?
How?
How is that Zeus?
Why does he have a microphone?
Guys, it's all about the theming.
Guys, oh...
I'm a...
Valkyrie.
Oh my god, breathtaking!
Yes!
Aide!
Best one yet!
Oh!
Oh, who's that?
What the fuck?
Get educated, you little child!
You baby!
Okay.
Alright, that phoenix gets two stars.
That phoenix...
Such...
I can't believe it!
This bitch said who's that!
Go back to fucking school before you go to fashion school!
Get an education!
I'm kidding!
Hahaha!
I'm Meg from Hercules movie.
Why do you have a...
Why do you have a basketball?
Hahaha!
No...
Why does she...
Oh!
Slave!
That shit is fire!
Oh my...
Five stars!
Oh my god!
Girl, you know what's up, girl!
Hahaha!
Oh my god...
Girl, you know what's...
You know what's up...
Slave girl.
Hahaha!
That's actually so good.
I forgot to do poses!
Oh, I can't!
Two stars.
10 out of 10.
She's a flop, bro.
Girl, you ate and left no crumbs.
Oh my god, is that like Twilight Sparkle?
Oh my god!
I know I can't be you because I'm me.
Good doki.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is her?
I'm do- Bro, what?!
Why do I look like trash?!
I'm from Etsy.
No one knows who this is.
I think doki bird...
is a pretty cool individual.
She's pretty slay.
Doki bird from Etsy.
Who is doki bird lol?
I heard she's like, she's a fashion vlog.
Vlog.
I see.
Sorry.
Alright, who's next?
Alright.
Who the fuck is this girl?
You're- You're- Are you trying to say women are a myth?
Like, are you trying to say women are- What are you?
You're just women.
Women.
Yeah!
Oh shit.
Like, I- I robbed- Okay, to be fair, I definitely robbed Medusa.
I def- I definitely- I definitely robbed her from the wind.
I def- The biggest upset of the century.
You did not deserve this.
Oh my god.
I definitely did not deserve this win.
Alright, Farmer.
Not enough theme props?
What do you mean?
Oh, I need a buy to decide the theme?
The rich really do decide the world.
The rich- The rich yet again.
Yet again.
Props.
The rich runs this world.
Oh my god.
Somebody put Farmer in there!
Somebody pay to put Farmer in the fucking category chat.
What the fuck is this?
Is this parkour?
The theme is sci-fi.
Shit.
Where the fuck do I be in sci-fi?
No, I'm not.
I don't feel ready.
Um...
Oh no.
Where do I be in sci-fi?
What would be...
Star Trek?
These children don't know what the fuck is Star Trek!
You know what?
Is Miku...
Wait, Miku Hatsune is technically sci-fi.
You think...
Is Miku sci-fi?
Is she sci-fi?
You know what?
Wait, you're gonna be Miku?
Bitch.
Take that shit off right now.
You're not gonna be Miku.
I'm gonna be Miku.
Girl, I was here first and I'm gonna be Miku.
That's right.
That's...
Turn around.
Turn around right now.
That's fucking right.
Know your place.
Know your goddamn place, child.
Know your...
That's so cute, right?
That's good that she knew her place.
That's...
That's the...
That's the actual fashion drama.
I am a rising star in the...
I will be the one then.
That's right.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, there we go.
We got the right colors.
And then...
Oh wait, that has to be black so...
There we go.
Alright.
But... that's right.
And then... we're gonna have to get the hair.
We're gonna grab the hair here.
I'm not gonna socialize with the...
with those beneath me right now.
Like, I'm a star.
I'm a goddamn fucking star.
I'm not gonna socialize...
with those that are beneath my existence.
Wait, where's the Miku hair?
Where's the Miku hair?
Wait...
Where is it?
She literally had Miku hair.
It's from my code?
What's the code, guys?
Guys, what's the code?
I need the code.
I can't live without it.
How do I...
Guys...
What's the code?
Guys, we have two...
We have two...
There's...
What's the code?
There's a code.
The code is four.
Guys, we need the Miku hair.
It's not boobs.
I Bella slay.
Okay.
That's not numbers.
That's an invalid code.
Oh, is it all... Is it L?
L Bella slay.
Is it L?
Oh, is it I?
I.
Oh my god.
Slay.
Okay.
Come on.
Miku hair color.
There we go.
I am sci-fi.
Miku is sci-fi.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're giving Miku some sci...
You know, I can pick whatever the fuck I want.
I own this... I own this fashion industry.
I... Like, I've never changed my makeup at all.
I've never...
I haven't changed my makeup at all throughout the year.
But this, like...
I just...
I just kept this on since...
Since the very start.
Okay.
Let's see.
I could be Vampire Miku.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be Vampire Miku.
Mewing.
I'm gonna be...
I'm gonna...
I'm mewing right now.
Now I'm viewing Miku.
This is the time I'm viewing Miku.
Alright, let's see.
And then get the microphone.
There we go.
Hatsune Miku.
Yes!
Yes, children!
I'm Hatsune Miku!
That's right, children.
Oh my gosh, she's the angel from Doctor Who!
I can't believe you guys were like, these children will never recognize Star Trek.
They'll just be like, they literally was like, who the fuck is Jackie?
They don't even know who Jackie was.
They saw Michelle Obama and was like, oh I know her.
And then everybody else was like, who the fuck is she?
What is that?
That's not even sci-fi.
What are you?
God.
Is this why you do not have VIP?
That's right.
Um, it's Hatsune Miku.
Get it right, girl.
Like, oh my god.
Get it right.
Is that Shaggy?
Miku?
I'm Hatsune Miku.
Hahaha.
It's giving.
Oh my god.
That face is giving five stars.
So good!
Thank you, darlings.
Thank you.
I love it.
Slay.
That phone.
No, I forgot to pose!
I keep forgetting to pose!
I got so absorbed.
I don't need to pose.
I own the industry.
Ladies.
Who's that?
Is this a... who's that?
Who the fuck is that?
I don't know what this is.
Don't need a pose.
All my sides are my good side.
Wait, oh my god!
Five stars though.
Five stars.
Guys, give Jay five stars.
That is beautiful.
No way!
Is that...
Is that sci-fi doki bird?
Guys, you better... Oh!
E from Wall-E!
That was an attempt.
I don't know.
You're just not me.
You're just... it's... it's... you're just not me.
Like, I don't know.
That's actually... Oh, wait!
That's actually pretty good.
That's... you know what?
With every Hatsune Miku needs a Lenn.
So you get... you get a four star.
You get a four star.
She thought she was her.
What the fuck is that?
Is that actually Shaggy?
Chat, is this Rin?
I'm separate timelines instead of VTubing.
I became a bioengineer.
I didn't even vote.
That's how fucked it was.
I hate green Shaggy.
Who's that?
I'm Wall-E.
Oh!
You're Wall-E!
One star.
I didn't know until you said you're Wall-E.
So, like, I don't know.
It had to be very... It has to be, like, very obvious to me that you're Wall-E.
If you have to tell me you're Wall-E, then it's not good enough.
I'm sorry, darling.
It's just not good enough.
It's just... mmm... You just need to try a little bit more.
I'm sorry, darling.
It's just...
mmm...
You just need to try a little bit more.
I am...
Is that Tom Cruise?
Wait, who's this?
Is that cosplaying as a scientific tomato?
T-star.
Scientific experiment.
Cute.
If the tomato can be... No, a tomato.
If the tomato can be a fashion model, what will it look like?
What are you?
I don't know.
I just did... Okay, one star.
You didn't even try.
You're a runway queen and you didn't even try?
God, whose daddy helped you get here at the top?
Somebody clearly used daddy's money to get here.
Get out.
What the fuck?
This bit is really good.
Slay.
That person was AFK.
Alright, the winners are...
YAAAAAAAAY!
Hatsune Miku!
I think I fucked up this lobby.
Guys, I'm pretty sure I messed up the lobby, guys.
Take a photo!
Take photos!
Oh my gosh.
Come on, paparazzi.
Go over here and take some photos of my true rifle plays here.
Don't worry.
I might not have posed... Oh, yeah.
That's right.
That's right, everybody.
Oooh.
Yeah.
That's right.
Do pose 12.
What's pose 12?
Is this?
Is this a JoJo pose?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Wow.
Guys, I'm a natural.
I'm actually a natural at this.
Now I know why Kesa was obsessed with this.
Wait, I can join the...
Oh, I can join the VIP exclusive servers?
Oh, guys.
I need a real challenge, everybody.
I...
I need a real challenge.
I think as a rising star that I made it in this world to go the next level.
Okay.
Elements.
Oh, God.
Wait, elements.
Okay.
Go to... Oh, they're fire.
Okay, if they're gonna be fire, I'm gonna be water.
I'm gonna be water.
I'm thinking quick right now.
I'll be water.
Alright.
Guys.
I'm sorry, but like clearly...
Clearly, I deserve to be here.
Because I got so many wins, guys.
So, I mean...
All I'm saying is that I am...
I think I am ready to be in the big leagues.
I'm ready to be in the big leagues now.
Hahaha.
Oh, yes.
Okay, we're gonna...
Alright.
We're gonna be the element of water.
Oh, okay.
Let's see.
What is good?
Or should I have a body suit?
Wait, should I have this on?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
Let me...
Doing our Gucci villain arc.
No, I feel like...
Since like...
Wait, how...
How are they doing this?
Why are they like mermaids?
You guys saw that, right?
They were like mermaids at one point.
Like, how are they mermaids?
Let's see.
Nope.
Uh...
God, we'll be a good fit.
Ooh.
Yes.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Yes!
Code?
Guys, we need to be a mermaid.
Guys, we're literally...
Code, give me the code.
Guys, we gotta win this.
We gotta beat these guys.
Guys, we gotta beat these guys.
We're in the big leagues, girls.
We're in the big leagues.
Mermaid.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
Oh, you're gonna...
You're gonna beat this competition, doki.
Oh, my God.
Like...
They don't know what's coming.
Oh, my God.
Guys, we gotta grab this hex code and then change this to this and then change this to this.
There we go.
Wait, what?
This is not the code?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my God.
You are so...
You're ready.
You're so ready, doki.
You have to think.
An hour ago, you were just beneath them.
And look at this.
Look at you now, girl!
Oh, my God.
It is possible.
Anybody can be a star.
Anybody can be a star if you just try hard enough.
And if you...
If you can't...
You were just weren't trying.
Let's see.
All right.
He wants to try.
You just weren't giving your all.
That's all I'm saying.
You can't make it here.
You weren't trying your best.
What is this?
Oh yes!
It's like seaweed!
I can make this like seaweed!
Oh my god!
Yes!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's like nature.
God, how do you keep doing this?
How are you just so good?
Oh my god.
Wait, this works.
Wait, this actually works.
How are you just... Oh my gosh, Doki.
You're literally a natural at this.
I'm trying to figure out if I want this fit.
Like the dress with the...
Oh, but maybe if I put a belt on it?
Like if I put a belt on top?
And then...
Oh no, the belt doesn't...
The belt... Oh, I can make it bigger?
Wait, how do I...
Is that not the belt?
Where is it?
No, I can't.
I can't fit the belt.
Oh my god.
Let's see.
That's what you're going in?
It's called elements, girl.
What element are you?
The element of shit?
You might as well leave now.
Don't even bother going to the judging panel.
Wow.
You are so rude.
Okay.
That's when I know I am in the big leagues.
Oh my God.
You can tell.
Doki, these are children.
Age doesn't matter in the world of fashion.
You either have it or you don't.
One star.
What element are you?
Are you trendsetter?
More like go home.
What even is this?
The element of lady.
What element is this?
Oh, that's fire?
But I know this is from... I don't know.
Fire.
More like go homer.
What is this?
Is this nature?
Girl, look at color theory.
Go back to school to figure out what color theory is.
More like belongs in the trash.
Oh, and that's how you do Earth, Bella!
Maybe you should go back to the free section.
Oh, that's how you do Earth, girl.
Yes!
Slay!
Fire!
Can we get some snaps?
Now that's an Earth element.
That's really good.
What the fuck is this?
Water and fire?
No.
Do not mix.
Water and fire don't go together.
Oh, they're talking about elements.
Okay.
But what about elemental dokey?
That's a children's film.
Water.
That's all I'm gonna write.
No.
No, I forgot to pause!
I keep forgetting to pause!
What is... Snow is not an element!
You wish it was an element!
Have you never played Pokemon before?
Fire!
Wa... Oh, wait.
It's ice!
Snow is not ice!
It's just water.
Snow isn't an element.
That's not even ice!
That's air?!
I'm third?!
That bitch is not even air!
How can you tell it's air?!
Fucking clowns!
The first thing I see is like not... God, this lobby is so beneath me.
They cannot see real talent.
No!
I'm not Pro-X!
How many points do I have?!
How many... How many points do I have?!
I...
Snow is not...
That's truly a streamer...
How do I... How many points do I have?!
I have a hundred and sixty f... Can you gift stars?
Or do you have to grind that shit out?
Yeah, that's what you deserve.
I wanna... I wanna be in the big leagues.
These bitches don't deserve me.
I got third place, chat.
I got third... from first place.
Favorite aesthetic?
What a garbage fucking... I'm doing another snow.
Fuck this server.
What a garbage element.
That's not even like... um... That's not even a real theme.
Oh my god!
Get me outta here!
This theme fucking sucks!
This is... third is not... third...
That's a non-theme.
That's literally a cop-out.
I need a real challenge.
It's still favorite aesthetic?!
Am I... There's only one server?!
Tell me when this aesthetic is over.
I can't... I can't deal with that.
I can't deal with people giving like... um... I... It can be anything, Zine.
That's not... You either...
You gotta go hard or go home.
You can't just be like... um... I like any... Minimalist versus maximalist.
What the fuck is that?
The...
Just don't fucking put on anything.
Like what?
Oh... wait.
Wait, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Okay, okay.
Where... where is... there we go.
Wait, can I change?
No!
No, I can't!
I don't have any clothes on.
Alright, where's like the... where's like the... the... the... I'm cooking.
I'm cooking.
I'm cooking something right now.
I need like the shortest thing they have.
So I can do something silly.
I need something... I need like a bikini.
Where's the...
Oh, yes!
Okay, what... what color is this?
I can color match this, guys.
I can do it.
I can color match this.
Guys, it'll be easy.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
I'll spend the entire time color matching this until I got... get it perfect.
I... uh...
What the fuck is that?
Okay, wait.
It's almost there.
We're almost there.
We're almost there, guys.
Okay, there you go.
That's the best I can do.
Okay, we need like...
It's like minimalist!
I'm literally... I'm giving the minimalist look right now!
What do you want from me?
Literally minimalist, chat.
I'm doing my best here to give you nothing.
No, God, don't give us nothing!
If they didn't want me to do all of that, I... they would have taken that theme out.
Like...
If they didn't want this, this would not be a theme.
They know damn well how... what's gonna happen.
They know damn well what would happen.
Alright, let's see.
Need like...
What do you give us?
That is... it's so minimal!
How is this not minimalist?
How do they have a fucking bra, but no... no like... I don't know, shorts or tights or like... uh... bikini bottoms?
Alright, let's see.
I mean, this is the closest we have.
This is literally... there we go.
Oh wait, this is a better...
Wait, I think this is better.
Like the source code for this.
Okay, uh...
Wait, I should really like this.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's the wrong one.
Oh no, I still have time, I still have time.
That's the wrong one.
This is it.
No, I keep pressing the wrong one!
What?
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Yes, girl.
It's literally... they literally said... no, they said minimalist.
I'm giving you nothing.
How am I supposed to know this?
How am I losing?
This is perfect!
This is as minimal as you can get!
I don't understand how this is a loss.
This is literally as minimal...
Okay, okay, fine, fine, fine, fine.
There, at least... at least I have shoes on.
There we go.
This is as minimal as you can get.
There's no way.
There's no way!
This is literally as minimal as you can get!
My fashion sense is so ahead of its time.
You guys just don't understand.
Guys, you're not a trendsetter like me.
Is this ethical?
What do you mean?
Laffy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is it true?
It's like minimalist logos.
It's literally it.
They said maximalist and I took it personally.
I don't know.
Like...
The colors look terrible.
I hate the colors.
That's just my opinion though.
You may not be ready for it, but your kids are gonna love it.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god!
And she's showing what she's got.
Damn!
She ain't no lady.
That's for sure.
Okay, my posing will save me.
Oh, wait.
I do love...
I do...
I do like...
Wait, you can have an umbrella?
Where did she get the umbrella?
Where did...
She's serving right now.
She's ser...
What is it?
She's serving cunt?
Is that what they call it?
Is that what they call it in the fashion industry?
Okay.
Yeah.
That's why I said no.
Okay.
She's serving cunt.
I don't know why.
I did...
Okay.
And this is...
She's so soft.
Okay.
No, you don't deserve to start.
I got distracted there.
Oh my god, that is the most... oh my god, that is so maximalist.
She should go to jail for this.
She should go to jail.
All right, is it my turn?
What is it?
Miss America.
Holy shit, what a fucking name.
Miss Americana.
One star.
How is that minimal?
You're just a woman, like with headphones on.
How is that minimalist?
That's right.
As minimal as you can get, girl.
Now this is minimalist.
No way.
I'm mannequin chic right now.
No pose...
Exactly... if I'm gonna be minimal...
We don't even pose...
That was on purpose.
YEAH!
WE ARE INSPIRED!
Guys, take a photo.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
That's it, guys.
Take some photos.
Okay?
Snapshots guys, come on.
Take all these.
I'm gonna do a mannequin posing for you.
Oh yeah.
Yeah girl!
Spread those legs!
Spread those legs and...
She cut.
Holy shit.
Okay let's go back to the...
Let's go back.
I'm done with you guys.
You guys are too easy.
You guys are too fucking easy.
I'm going back to my VIP lounge.
I'm sorry.
You're not a challenge.
Children.
I need to go where...
I know my talents...
will be appreciated.
Childhood dream?
Oh okay.
Childhood dream.
She's still serving it.
Alright.
Childhood dream.
I know there's a balloon.
What's my childhood dream?
Guys we gotta mix shit up.
Like reality TV.
Nothing is real.
Who entered that fashion?
What do you mean?
That's as minimal as you can fucking get.
How dare you.
My childhood dream...
is to be a rabbit.
I don't fucking know.
A clown?
Oh my god.
You're right.
Wait you're right.
Okay.
I know there was a balloon here.
There was a balloon somewhere.
Oh my god.
You're right guys.
A clown.
I'm gonna steal that idea and then pick it mine.
Just like fashion.
Just like fast fashion.
Exactly like fast fashion.
Okay I need a...
Alright let's see.
Um...
It won't be that.
We're gonna pick a random makeup.
Wait actually is there clown makeup?
Holy shit.
What the fuck is that?
Oh there is!
Nice there's clown makeup.
That's good.
We won't be a clown.
Okay we need a...
Okay we need white makeup.
And then... Oh there's the balloon.
There's the balloon.
Okay red and then...
Uh...
White.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Somebody wants to be a mermaid?
Mermaids aren't real.
You're a fucking...
stupid child.
Mermaids aren't real child.
Alright let's see.
White there we go.
Alright.
Not a clown.
Somebody is in fucking denial.
Childhood dream.
Alright let's see.
I need... Oh my god they're all VIPs right now.
Oh wait no not this.
I need to go to get my hair done.
I need to get my hair done.
Breaker of dreams.
Uh...
Let's see.
I need like short hair.
Oh I could do like...
Uh do I want pom poms or...
No I'll do this hair.
And then I'm basically Harley Quinn.
I'm basically Harley Quinn.
Okay.
Oh I don't know.
I don't know about the bangs situation.
Oh okay you know what?
You know what?
I like it.
I think I like it.
I think I can make it work.
I can make this work.
And then red.
White.
Oh yes I can definitely make this work.
Um...
I feel like...
Wait maybe if I do white.
And then red.
No I'm gonna do...
I'm gonna do this.
I think this is better.
Yeah yeah yeah this is definitely better.
Harley Quinn is in...
Harley Quinn is real to me.
Harley Quinn is literally a therapist.
Therapist.
That means you're saying therapists aren't real.
That's...
She's literally a therapist.
Let's see.
Oh the tutu.
Where's the tutu?
Where is it?
Guys is tutu in the poor section or the rich section?
Oh there.
It's in the poor section.
Alright and then...
Can I do like double patterns?
Oh yes.
Oh give me that gene mod texture.
Alright let's see.
Alright.
Uhh...
Need like...
No I don't like that actually.
No no no no no.
Maybe this would be better.
I mean like grab.
Ah I don't know what to put on my shirt.
Guys I need to figure out...
The corset!
There's a corset!
Oh my god.
Where's the corset?
Where is it?
Guys, where the fuck is the corset?
Is this?
Yes!
Yes, girl!
Yes.
Oh my god, yes girl.
You know how to bring it.
Oh my god, you truly are... you're her.
You're actually her.
Holy shit.
These children don't know what fashion really is until I came along.
Oh my god.
You wanna be a princess?
You mean you didn't grow up...
You wanna be a goddamn princess?
Oh my god.
What small dreams you have.
Okay.
What's this?
Two princesses?
Clearly you guys have zero creativity.
Um, if you all... I mean... I mean princess is a choice if you're two.
This is the big leagues right now.
Seize the clown.
What the fuck is that?
A mermaid?
Rabbit?
I wanted to be a mermaid but this is what I wanted me as a role mermaid to look like.
Holy shit.
Even as a doll, you don't know what colors mean.
Was that another mermaid?
Mermaid?
I got...
Trendsetter?
Trendsetter of the poor.
I wanna be Ursula but pretty?
Holy shit.
That's so fucked.
What is that?
I wanted to work with frogs and other things.
Okay.
You know what?
That's really good.
That's actually really good.
She wanted... Basically she wanted to be a fucking frog.
Does it mean?
I wanted to be a clown.
That's right.
Yeah, look at that.
Clowns.
Don't go outside.
No, I shouldn't say that to the child.
Whoa.
Look, I didn't... I didn't say it.
I didn't type.
I didn't press enter.
I didn't... I didn't press enter chat.
Let's see.
She wants to be... She wants to be the cheerleader for the Dallas Cowboys.
Cow, I'm glad you could achieve your dream.
What the fuck?
There's two cheer...
Guys, girls, aim higher.
You almost said that.
That's crazy.
I said...
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Get it, get it, boom.
Boom, ba-da-da.
What?
The cheerleader won?
Are you fucking...
I'm eighth?
Princesses.
Two girls wanted to be princesses?
And then we had two mermaids.
This is... This is rigged.
This is actually rigged.
Like...
This is actually...
Fucked.
Like...
You don't deserve to be up here.
I forgot what kids like.
I'm a fun... Kids like clowns.
Why the fuck would people hire clowns?
At parties?
If kids didn't like them?
Oh my god.
This is not fair.
What child wants to be a clown?
Wait, everybody left.
Everybody...
What?
Everybody left.
Wait...
Everybody...
They all left.
They...
They actually formed a clique.
Like, that's so fucked.
We played one game and a clique was formed.
Like...
I don't know.
We played...
Oh shit.
Spice Girls.
I don't fucking know.
I don't remember what they looked.
Bro.
Spice Girls?
With children?
Like...
Children don't know...
What...
Children don't know what Spice Girls are.
Literally someone's gonna dress as a literal spice.
Cause that's what they think Spice Girls are.
They...
Someone's gonna dress as a hot chili pepper.
Cause they don't know what...
What the fuck a Spice Girl is?
Like...
Hahahaha Hahahaha Look!
Like she's really a fucking chili pepper!
The children don't know what it is!
Like...
That's actually...
Sorry...
Who's thought of this theme?
Um...
Might be better to be honest.
Hahahaha Okay...
Alright, last game guys!
Last game!
I did not...
I did not think I'd get this absorbed into Dressed to Impress guys.
Dressed to Impress has been fucking wild.
Alright...
What the fuck?
Hahahaha Hahahaha I can't...
I can't...
Holy shit!
What the...
Hahahaha I literally just joined this to see that!
That's actually crazy!
Holy shit!
Holy fucking shit!
That's actually crazy!
That this is not what I joined in!
Hahahaha No...
Can I even make myself?
Like...
I don't even...
Alright...
Oh...
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
What are the odds though?
Like...
Hahaha What are the fucking odds?
Hahaha For some that don't even know what that is!
Like...
I'm like looking around and I'm like...
What the fuck?
Like...
Let's see...
Um...
Yeah...
Yeah, that's right.
That seems right!
That seems fucking right!
Hahahaha That seems right!
Hahaha Let's see...
Wait...
Is there like...
Is there...
Is there my hairstyle in here?
Hahaha Hahaha Haha...
Yeah...
Hahaha Hahaha Hahaha Look as dead inside as possible.
Why does she look so...
Oh wait!
Wait!
I'm not corp!
Hahaha!
Shit!
You're right!
I'm indie!
Fuck!
Okay!
You know what?
This is awkward.
We're all dead inside anyway.
You're right!
Hahaha!
I forgot!
I'm indie!
Give me a sec!
I gotta...
I gotta figure something out!
I don't fucking know!
Hahaha!
Ha ha ha!
Holy shit!
Bro, I'm just gonna give nothing!
This is what we're all like inside.
This is what we all look like inside.
Hahaha!
I'm the manager!
You're right!
I'll just be like that.
I'll be like, I'm the manager!
Hahaha...
Hahaha!
Okay, let's see.
Let me at least change my shirt.
Now that I know.
Guys!
I see what you tried!
I'm an indie!
You already failed the challenge!
Okay, there we go.
Should have liked the blue earlier though.
Oh, not that blue.
Okay, well.
Not that blue.
Holy shit!
I can't believe I actually got this theme.
That's actually fucking crazy.
That's the last match.
That's actually insane.
Holy fuck.
Is that supposed to be the end?
Is that supposed to be me?
I...
Five stars if it is.
Oh my god!
It's TokiBird!
The indie Vtuber!
What's this?
Batty, girl.
Who the fuck is that?
Is that me?
Who the fuck is this?
NicoleTV?
Who the fuck is NicoleTV?
PrestonPlays?
These are not Vtubers!
Is it just... Is it just the...
I'm the... I'm the manager.
Yeah!
Oh!
Isn't that the...
the... from the fucking...
that new anime show?
About the girl being Vtuber?
Thing?
Isn't that...
Isn't that it?
That new anime show?
From the... from...
What was it about that Vtuber anime show?
What was it that?
Yeah, there's a new anime show about like Vtubers.
Vtuber legend?
About how this Vtuber was fucking like going there and then was like...
And then like she had a hot mic situation where she was super vulgar and wasn't actually like the cute Vtuber.
Legendary Vtuber!
Yeah!
Yeah, that's it!
I heard it's really funny.
I heard that show was really, really funny.
Is that Jerma?
Is that...
What the fuck?
What the fuck is like some of these bits?
Like...
Wait!
There's two of them?
That's not fair!
I'm fucking leaving.
How dare they...
This is rigged!
How is there two?
Fuck this guys.
I'm rebooting.
This should not be last game.
I can't believe there's two.
That's cheating!
Why is there two of them?
That's actually cheating!
Like...
That's zero stars.
I can't believe... It's already rigged before I even started.
I got in!
Alright, Preppy.
That's actually cheating.
Holy fuck.
I can't believe it.
Why can they do two?
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Casino Night?
Okay, this is LG.
This is LG for real.
Let's go gambling!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
How do I... Wait, how do I duo up with somebody?
How do I do that?
How do I duo?
I wanna duo with some...
Oh, dang it.
Top icon?
Where is it?
This one?
Oh shit!
Okay.
What the...
Oh fuck.
Alright.
Let's... I don't know.
Who has... Alright.
Monkey girl.
Let's duo.
Okay, wait.
Alright, let's see.
Casino Night.
Uh...
What is...
Okay.
I don't know who I invited.
Casino Night.
We're bringing it back.
We're gonna reuse the same look as before.
It's the same look as before.
What do you mean?
I'm literally gambling!
How the fuck is that Casino Night?
You're literally...
Oh, wait.
They're duoing?
Wait, that's not fair!
That's not fair!
Why do they have friends?
How dare they?
How fucking...
dare they have friends?
I'm so insulted.
Like...
We're gonna re...
You know what?
What would it look like if we like...
Oh, we can't do that?
What's the point?
Alright.
That's not fair.
I can't believe they have friends.
I can't fucking believe it.
Alright.
Red.
Woah!
What?
How do you have six wings?
It's Casino Night, not Satanic Night!
Like...
Bro, why is everybody a Satan?
Wait, what?
Why is...
Okay, but like, why?
Why is every... Like, literally, why is everybody fucking angels and devils?
Is this what they think gambling is?
Is this what you children think gambling is?
Like...
I think...
There's no way it's what children think gambling is.
It's like the fucking...
It's like the...
The game of...
The game of evil.
Gambling is the work of the devil.
Gambling is...
Gambling is a sin, Doki.
How dare you What the fuck?
What the fuck?
Gambling is either the best thing in the world, or a fucking sin.
Dressed like a casino dealer.
I can't!
There's no outfit!
I don't have enough time!
Oh, wait.
A tie.
I'll be like, I'm the casino... I'm the...
I'm the casino dealer that didn't follow the dress code.
I didn't follow the dress code.
God, the fuck.
Alright, we're good.
This is how we're gonna end it.
How
the fuck?
Okay.
How is this... How is this casino night?
I look...
Jesus Christ!
Jesus fucking Christ!
Okay.
Your outfit is...
Now...
Like...
How is this cas... How is this casino night?
I'm calling you out.
I'm calling you fucking out.
It's a nice fit.
How is any of this casino night?
No, we changed the theme!
You can't!
What?
I'm just kidding!
So fucked!
We don't like the next theme, then you can't!
Bro!
I...
I just can't!
Bro...
I... I wasn't there for the theme change!
Oh my god!
This is so fucking rigged!
This is a fucking click!
Like...
This is actually so fucked!
Holy shit!
I thought it was a fucking game for children!
How is there groups already?
The race spoiled you again!
Cas, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Why are children so...
I'll just be like, gambling is a sin, so technically I'm a double!
I'll say that!
I'll say that at the moment!
I miss...
Bro, I wasn't invited to the fucking theme change!
Children literally forming cliques is crazy!
Johnny, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hahaha!
I got played by god damn children!
Oh my god!
This is not...
Hahaha!
I didn't say that!
Holy shit!
I lost lay!
That's fucking right!
Okay, hun!
Bro!
What the fuck did you hunt me?
I...
I hate children so much!
I hate kids!
I...
I hate children!
Fuck children!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
She didn't know we changed the theme!
I...
I got there when...
when everyone was already tripping off!
Bro, I...
I hate children.
I hate children so much!
Holy shit!
I hate...
Imagine getting a cape by a six year old!
God damn children!
How do I make my own server?
I need to boost my ego.
How the fuck do I make my own server?
Hahaha!
Children are evil!
Children deserve nothing!
I need to make my own server!
Hahaha!
Where is it?
How do I do it?
I have a hundred robux!
Oh that was one of the LGs of all time!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Give me a sec!
I'm fucking making my own server!
I... I need this!
I actually...
How do I do it?
How do I make my server?
I truly are.
Call the server!
Bro, she is...
okay honey!
That's actually so fucked!
I can't believe...
I'm fucking making my own... I can't believe she okayed honey!
Vote for Doki.
Hahaha!
Okay.
My server's name is Boost Doki's Ego.
Like...
Hahaha!
Join me.
Alright.
There we go.
Okay.
Actually, no kids allowed.
JK!
Hahaha!
That's my...
That is my new server.
My server is called No Kids Allowed.
That's my server.
Hahaha!
I've had it.
I've had it with these children in my Roblox game.
Fucking changing the theme at the la- during...
That is so fucked.
That is actually so fucked.
Like, I'm so mad.
I'm so fucking mad.
Hahaha!
Guys, my server name is No Kids Allowed.
How do I like send you guys the link to my server?
How do I send you guys the link to my server?
Chat.
No kids allowed.
Alright.
Invite friends.
Okay, I can't invite friends.
Okay, settings.
Uhhh...
If it weren't for the...
If it weren't for the stupid kids!
Hahaha!
Okay, configure.
Alright, friends.
Okay, join.
Okay, here we go.
I got it.
I got the link.
Okay.
Hahaha!
Stupid Now it's LG.
Now it's LG.
Guys, alright, we're gonna make our own theme.
If those kids can make their theme, we're gonna make our own- we're gonna do FNAF.
I say we do FNAF!
This is what I wanted.
I want FNAF, children!
I want FNAF!
No, actually all Dokis.
JK, all Dokis.
Give me your best Doki.
I want your best fucking Dokis right now.
And you can- and bonus points if you slip in some FNAF in there too.
Alright.
Hahaha!
The Dokiverse.
Bring in the Dokiverse!
Hahaha!
I want- I want the Dokiverse right now.
No, I have to pay for that!
I don't have it!
I want the Dokiverse, guys!
Ignore- ignore this!
We make our own theme.
Hahaha!
I want Dokiverse.
The theme is trendy.
Hahaha!
If they can make their theme, this is my clique.
This is my Dragoon clique.
That's right.
I want the Dokiverse.
I know what I'm gonna be.
I know- hahaha!
Hahaha!
I know- I know what I'm going to be.
The Dread Doki.
Hahaha!
Alright, let's see.
Do not be afraid.
Hahaha!
Let's see.
Um...
Fucking children.
I hate kids.
Hahaha!
I'm so okay- oh, we changed the theme.
Sorry, we didn't tell you.
Even though, like, we know that you just got here, like, we didn't tell you that we actually changed the theme.
Hahaha!
I hate children.
I'm so tilted.
Yes, I am tilted!
I- my outfit was so good!
This all is real.
I had such a good outfit!
And then they were like, oh sorry.
Oh sorry.
And then they okayed Hunmi.
Like, that's the most insulting part.
A fucking 13 year old.
I bet you they weren't even 13.
A fucking 10 year old fucking okayed Hunmi.
Bitch.
Hahaha!
They're just kids.
It's fucking real life now.
This is- This is a serious game.
Hahaha!
This is a very serious game.
This is- this is the most serious game of my life.
Hahaha!
We need something.
We need like, green hair at the top.
We need like- I don't need real gaming.
It's a lot.
Alright, we need like a s- a green hair somewhere.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, I don't - This is crazy!
That's what I was fucking saying!!!!!
I'm fine if the child did an okay huh, Hunmi.
Then I would have been fine.
I would have- I can't with my ego.
It's gone.
Did we learn not to tilt you?
I spent a hundred ropmex just to make myself feel better.
Hahaha!
I'm done.
Oh my god.
This is it.
I'm actually... oh my god.
My fit is perfect.
My fit is actually perfect.
You know kids, I actually spent a hundred Robux just to feel better about myself.
That was okay, really mind-broker beyond belief.
Ivy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bro, I'm already done.
I fucking beat so many kids that I know exactly what my fit is gonna be.
I hate those kids.
Kids are fucking ruthless!
They don't have... they haven't learned what empathy is.
So they say whatever the fuck they want.
They're so mean.
I hate children.
There's a crow key.
Where?
Who the fuck is that guy?
That guy.
Wait, there's a crow key.
Oh my god, there is!
Okay guys, we shouldn't spoil ourselves.
Let's look outside the window.
Guys, we can't spoil ourselves, guys.
Again.
Oh my god.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Those Overwatch players, GoBarts, DPS players, move through this game because these kids know how to deal damage.
Damn it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, we can't spoil ourselves, guys.
It's gotta be a surprise.
Alright, let's figure out some poses.
Let's figure out some poses that we can do.
Alright, let's see.
Ooh.
Ooh!
Yes!
Okay, what is this?
Is that 8?
Guys, remember 8 for me.
Guys, we gotta remember pose 8.
Oh, this is the one.
Sprint.
This is the one that she kept doing.
Okay, we gotta remember 8.
Pose 8.
Okay.
Let's see.
Ooh.
Yes, girl.
Alright, 20.
We're serving some tomato juice right now.
Right here.
Oh, where am I grabbing?
Is that...
Want some of this?
You want some of that tomato juice?
No, I shouldn't say that.
Shit.
It's not fair.
Like, come on.
Oh, manly duo.
Okay.
Hand on heart?
What is that?
Oh, like that.
Oh!
Leg out.
Girl!
I already leg out.
Okay.
Yes!
Leg out.
What was the number?
Guys!
Guys, I forgot!
I forgot the number!
888!
Oh, yes!
That's fucking right.
Easy.
Absolutely...
Absolutely insane fit, girl.
Insane...
What... What doki is this?
Which doki is this doki?
The...
One star.
You're not gonna be in the...
You're not gonna be in the board of doki.
That's for sure.
Don't worry.
No.
You don't call us.
We'll call you.
Which doki?
I tried it.
Oh!
Summer outfit!
Two stars.
Wouldn't they have a green shirt?
You know what?
There's green in...
There's a green shirt.
One star.
Summer doki.
The...
Oh!
You know what?
Five stars.
That's...
Girl doki...
Doki...
Here's our card.
I hope you take our offer to be on the board of dokis.
Oh my god.
That's so good.
Why do I not have shoes?
I tried making them from memory and failed?
I'm literally right here.
Like...
What do you mean?
I'm...
I'm literally streaming right now.
What are you...
I'm watching you guys.
What do you...
What do you mean?
I tried making her from memory.
Like...
That girl was not pixie dookie or something.
I don't...
Guys.
Are you guys sandbagging for me to win?
Are you...
Oh, I like this.
This is it.
That was cute.
I like the... Oh my god, that's so cute!
Wait, that is so cute on my phone because I have a problem!
Oh, I like that.
That's cute.
Okay, CROQI.
Okay.
Wait, what did you say that got censored?
Was CROQI censored?
Like... Is CROQI censored?
Wait, that's so good!
CROQI, my beloved, we are like this.
This game is paid to win!
Oh, the accent.
God.
Alright, voting complete.
Oh, it's the round!
I'm so happy!
What the fuck is that?
From another Dokiverse, keep believing, dream as hard as you can.
The lashes are on fleek.
Sorry, I gave you one star because I wasn't paying attention.
Did I mean that you were one star?
Oh, wait!
That's current Doki.
Oh my god, five stars because it's current Doki.
Oh my god, she's serving.
That's right.
She's serving that.
See.
Who's this?
Doki Man Bird.
Please give me the honor of being an official Dokiverse character.
Doki Man Bird!
You have to be specific about the gender of birds.
Like...
Doki Bird!
That's a new...
Yes!
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Wait, I can literally make a private server and just farm.
Guys, I can...
Wait.
This is actually pay to win.
I can...
I can literally have a custom server and then like...
I can farm 3000.
Holy shit.
Guys, guys, guys.
All the Dokis, take a picture right here.
Guys, before the timer's up, all the Dokis!
Get over here!
We gotta take a picture!
Guys!
Not you.
Not Uzi.
You're not Doki.
I'm joking.
I'm gonna be front and center.
Alright, guys.
Wade, get back here, Wade!
Wade, you tapped out!
Wade!
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna be here.
Alright, guys.
Do a pose.
Alright, nice.
Alright, guys.
Take a picture.
Alright.
Take a picture, everybody.
That's right.
With all the Dokis and Wade.
Wade is literally tapped out right now.
Holy shit.
Alright.
GG's.
GG's, guys.
I'm done.
I'm done with Roblox.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I spent 100 Roblox.
I'm fucking...
Let me cancel my Roblox.
Guys, I need to cancel my Roblox server.
So I...
Because it's like a monthly server.
And I need to be sure that I don't get charged.
Okay, guys.
Have fun.
You guys can have...
Guys, have fun, everybody.
For an entire month.
It expires on August 27th.
You guys can play Trested Impress on the No Kids Allowed server.
You guys...
You guys get the No Kids Allowed.
There will be no children allowed in that server.
I'll...
If there's a child, I will kick them out.
Alright.
I challenged...
I canceled the subscription.
Renewal canceled.
Thank fucking god.
I'm not...
I'm not letting the children ruin this...
ruin this for me.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's fun though.
That's fun.
Now I understand why...
Now I understand why this game was so popular.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Hope this helps as much as the Robux.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Donkey Farms showed you for money and rents for getting cake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You don't understand.
It's not even my fault.
That like I didn't know the theme.
I was not...
I joined in the server and nobody said anything.
Nobody said anything.
I was just making fun of people for having dog shit...
dog shit outfits.
Because I was like, oh look at these guys.
Not...
Not having the right clothes.
Like really...
I have a really normal , I hate that.
I don't know why they're like...
I didn't pay attention, I thought it was like three of them.
I didn't realize all twenty...
All thirteen of them wasn't following the theme.
How was I supposed to know?
Oh yeah, that's fun though.
That's a lot of fun.
Uh, I am gonna call it here guys.
I am tired.
I'm tired.
I'm gonna take a nap now.
But it was a great time playing Dressed to Impress.
And now I know why this game was super popular amongst the adults and the children.
So I hope you guys had fun as well!
Oh yeah, for those who don't know...
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I lost my train of thought regarding the K-So Tyler 1 shit.
So like in every generation, we will always have a streamer that likes to scream and yell at things and rage a lot.
But he's also a really good way for chat to bully as well.
He's like a really good streamer for chat to bully the streamer.
And each generation has its own version of that streamer.
The current one is K-So.
What I had was Tyler 1.
But yes, I'm gonna head off now everybody.
I think I read a lot of super chat.
Yeah, like a punching bag.
It's called the streamer... the punching bag streamer.
Exactly.
Anyway guys, I had a lot of fun today.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!